determine whether the following numbers
are prime composite or neither so just
as a bit of review a prime number is a
natural number so one of the counting
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 6 so on and so forth
that has exactly two factors so its
factors its factors are 1 and itself
one and itself so with an example of a
prime factor is 3 there's only two
natural numbers that are divisible into
3 1 & 3 another way to think about it is
the only way to get 3 is a product of
other natural numbers is 1 times 3 so it
only has 1 and itself
a composite a composite number is a
natural number that has more than just 1
and itself
as factors and we'll see examples of
that and neither we'll see an
interesting case of that in this problem
so first let's think about 24 so let's
think about all of the I guess you could
think of it as the natural numbers or
the whole numbers all those 0 is also
included in whole numbers let's think of
all of the natural counting numbers that
we can actually divide into 24 without
having any remainder we'd consider those
the factors well clearly it is divisible
by 1 and 24 in fact 1 times 24 is equal
to 24 but it's also divisible by 2 it's
also divisible by 2 2 times 12 2 times
12 is 24 so it's also divisible by 12
and it is also divisible by 3 3 times 8
is also equal to 24 and even at this
point we don't actually find have to
find all of the factors to realize that
it's not prime it clearly has more
factors than just 1 and itself
so then it is clearly going to be
composite pause it this is going to be
composite now let's just finish
factoring it just since we started it
it's also divisible by 4 and 4 times 6
had just enough space to do that
4 times 6 is also 24 so these are all of
the factors of 24 clearly more than just
1 and 24 and now let's think about 2
well
the whole the nonzero whole numbers that
are divisible into two well one times
two definitely works one and two but
there really aren't any others that are
divisible into two and so it only has
two factors 1 and itself
and that's the definition of a prime
number so 2 is prime 2 is 2 is prime and
2 is interesting because it's the only
it is the only even prime number only
even only even prime number and that
might be common sense to you because by
definition an even number is divisible
by 2 an even number is divisible by 2 so
2 is clearly divisible by 2 that's what
makes it even but it's only divisible by
2 and 1 so that's what makes it prime
but anything else that's divisible
that's even is going to be divisible by
1 itself itself and to any other number
that is even it's going to be divisible
by 1 itself and 2 so by definition it's
going to have 1 in itself and something
else so it's going to be composite so 2
is prime every other even number other
than 2 is composite now here's an
interesting here's an interesting case 1
1 is only divisible by 1 so it is not
prime technically because it is not it
only has 1 it only has 1 as a factor it
does not have two factors one is itself
but in order to be prime you have to
have exactly two factors one has only
one factor in order to be composite you
have to have more than two factors you
have to have one yourself and some other
things so it's not composite so one is
neither prime nor composite one is
neither and then finally we get to 17 17
is divisible 17 is divisible by 1 and 17
they're just not divisible by 2 not
difficult by 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 or 16
so it is it has exactly 2 factors 1 and
itself so 17 is once again 17 is prime